in Beirut Carlos gone faced the cameras
for the first time since his daring
escape from Japanese justice today is a
very important day for me one that I
have looked forward to every single day
for more than 400 days since I was
brutally taken from my world as I knew
it during a crest conference lasting
almost two and a half hours go and
claimed to have been the victim of a
conspiracy by those who were against his
plans to merge Nissan and Renault he
pointed fingers at Nissan executives
Tokyo prosecutors and elements within
the Japanese state I can talk about what
happens in the Government of Japan I can
give you names I know them but I am in
deben on I respect libanon and I respect
the hospitality that has extent been
extended to me by the authorities in
Lebanon and in no way I want to do
anything or say anything that would make
their task more difficult
Garin described his decision to flee
Japan inside this musical equipment box
as the most difficult choice of his life
new footage has emerged apparently
showing him being transferred between
private jets herd Istanbul Airport back
in Tokyo prosecutors raided the offices
of gones lawyer on Wednesday Junichiro
hironaka says he was as surprised as
anyone by his clients escape from Japan
now that he's out of the country
Carlos Cohen has shown he has no
intention of keeping quiet about why he
left and who he believes is to blame